one of apple's co-founders is accusing
the company's new digital credit card of
gender discrimination Apple introduced
the card in August partnering with
Goldman Sachs as the issuing bank
applicants go through a credit approval
process last week one tech entrepreneur
said the algorithms being used are
sexist Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak
tweeted that he got ten times the credit
limit his wife received even though they
have no separate accounts or a separate
assets Apple deferred to Goldman Sachs
which tells CBS News quote our credit
decisions are based on a customer's
creditworthiness and not on factors like
gender race age sexual orientation or
any other basis prohibited by law CBS
News contributor and Wired's
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson is here
Nick good morning good morning so cast
your mind back to the old old days you
apply for a credit card and somebody
sits behind a desk and looks over your
application now computers doing it sure
is this computer system at Apple flawed
it could be flawed it could be biased
one of the big problems of our time
right now is that biases are very hard
to pick out because they're built into
really complex algorithmic systems in
this particular case though there is
another explanation right Steve Wozniak
is one of the founders of Apple yes he
makes a long opinion yes and so if you
make a ton of money and your wife
doesn't and you apply four separate
cards you might get different credit
limits because your credit limit is
based on your credit score yeah but he
was saying they weren't segregated the
Apple cards you apply for different
accounts uh-huh so he's applying for a
different account there is an easy
explanation that doesn't mean the system
isn't biased it doesn't mean it isn't
rigged against women it's just the data
we have right now is not the most
compelling when you make algorithms more
transparent is that possible it is very
very hard because part of the nature of
artificial intelligence is that the
computer is making decisions that the
human doesn't make so for a lot of AI
algorithms you just say optimize for X
optimize for y so for example in credit
approvals you might say look at all the
data and optimize for a system that
minimizes defaults and then you don't
know what goes into that you're saying
some of these companies don't even know
how their own algorithms work they know
what the algorithms are trying to do
they don't know exactly
I think algorithm is getting there yeah
so you can try to audit it you can try
to break it apart you can look at
different factors take different inputs
but it is a complicated process it is
one of the most interesting questions of
our time how do we get justice in a
system where we don't know how the
algorithms are working well you could
argue for an algorithm because it's not
that old white bank manager making these
decision one guy behind a counter it's
now a machine and that doesn't have the
biases we do but but if the biases are
built-in because a programmer put them
there like your stuff or the data put
them there but one of the reasons why
when this story broke I was a little
skeptical is that probably the system is
set up to do what I said before right to
minimize defaults and a system that's
set to minimize defaults is not going to
give all men 20 times the credit limit
of all women perhaps it will have a tiny
difference based on historical data I
would expect maybe it would be
beneficial for women who are maybe more
responsible with their credit so this
story sounds like it probably the
outcome we're seeing is probably
connected to the very high income of the
tech founders tweeting about it so
doesn't it seem like there's a bigger
problem here than what it appears to be
I think this story is probably not the
best example of a huge issue all right
Nick Thompson thank you very much